[موسيقى]
نجد العدد الكبير ايضا من هؤلاء العلماء
الذين مروا على هذه المنطقه يعني اذا كان
في فتره الامام محمد بن سعود تقريبا حصرنا
العلماء من كتاب الشيخ عبد الله بن بسام
الذين في فتره الامام محمد بن سعود قرابه
94 الى المئه عالم فقط في فتره الامام
محمد بن سعود هناك فترات ايضا سابقه قديمه
ايضا لهؤلاء العلماء وتواجدهم ايضا في هذه
المنطقه لكن كانت النظره الكبيره لدى
المجتمع الحقيقه تركز ايضا على هذا الجانب
الذي ن ان نتطرق له وهو الجانب الامني
الذي ارى الذي استطع الامام علي
[موسيقى]
ما كان هناك قوه وسلطه سياسيه تجبر هؤلاء
على ايضا الامن والامان الذين يعني الذي
يتطلبوا هذا المجتمع ولهذا لدينا القاعده
الاساسيه في قيام الدوله والعنصر الكبير
انه الجانب الامني هو اعظم عامل لقيام
الدوله لان الناس اذكر لبعض الاخوه يقولون
ربما تجاوزت الجانب الديني او الجانب ايضا
الدعوي نقول لهم نحن نفقد الجانب الامني
ولم نفقد الدين الدين منذ وصول هذه
الرساله المحمديه صلى الله عليه وسلم ايضا
الى هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الامراء في هذه المنطقه عندما بدا ايضا
محمد بن سعود بفكره التنفيذ وايضا تطلع
للسلطه وايضا بث القوه وايضا النفوذ
لبلدان المجاوره الرياض سرمدا الخرج شعرها
هؤلاء بان هذا النفوذ سيؤثر عليهم ولذلك
واجهوه بالقوه
[موسيقى]